and he points at her and so she like
went to go move it okay
and that's when you just hear the loud
bang and a little bit of a light and
then she drops
and next you know she just starts to
bleed okay shocking moments we're seeing
for the very first time after a 13 year
old New Mexico girl is shot and killed
at the hands of a 14 year old boy
and he never and he was never mad about
anything
everyone was laughing having a good time
everybody was just having a good time
do you feel like he meant to do this
I don't know because if you think about
it he didn't seem mad or anything but
then why would he have his finger on the
trigger and just do that so I don't
really know the boy's father now also
charged in the girl's death as law
enforcement alleged his son easily
accessed the murder weapon from his
father's gun collection there's a lot of
guns in that house right and none of
them are secured
around okay with that with that right
there you have your hands put your hand
on your back the newly released body
camera video also shows the
heartbreaking reaction of the girl's
father when he learns for the first time
his daughter was murdered EMS just
pronounced her deceased oh my God oh my
God man body camera footage from July
28th shows First Responders arrive at
the scene in Cuesta New Mexico about two
hours north of Santa Fe
boom
their officials find 13 year old Amber
Archuleta shot and injured video
captures her brother frantic asking
whether she's still alive and I'm gonna
have to ask you bro what you're doing
right now is not helping I'm gonna need
you either go sit down over here or just
give us a second okay you don't need to
be upset I understand it's your sister I
understand but what you're doing right
now I understand but what you're doing
right now is not helping okay I'm not
trying to be an yeah you are I'm
not trying to be an apple too I'm trying
to help you buddy okay what you're doing
right now isn't helping please
well here's the here's the thing dude
the Medics are on the way all we can all
we can try to do is keep her alive while
the Medics are here
it's pretty good so can you please just
go over there and let us do our job
please sorry it's okay it's okay but I
understand you're upset I totally get it
I just need to step back for a second I
understand it's your sister and I
understand you love her we're gonna do
everything we possibly can to help her
okay I promise you I promise you that
okay it's okay it's okay I understand
your mouth I understand your magical I'd
be mad too let go buddy I'm gonna need
you to step back because the girls are
working on her let them work okay stop
yelling at him stop freaking out just
let us do our job okay
South Central with tier 16 Flags
foreign
together
four eight
sixteen so
I don't know dude I don't know right now
so tell me what happened
tell me what happened we don't remember
I'm out of it right now
does somebody pass by
um
you guys
I just did it was there where's the shop
that's what I'm trying maybe in front of
the face I don't know at first off
you're the girl was
drive-by shooting
while she got shot can you show me on
the street where it was supposedly it's
a drive-by that happened near the road
based on that information officers begin
searching the street area for evidence
I'm looking for a casing too down there
I don't see anything yet
they said it happened down here on the
street that's what I'm looking
hey Siri Okay Google
call Chief
sure
[Applause]
I'm not sure if it was down here he said
it seemed like the character up here but
this was closed
I'll try that next minutes later
Archuleta is pronounced dead and the
area becomes the scene of a Murder
clear the scene
um
let's get some tape and
start taping everything off tape
everything off put the unit in the road
I want to block off whatever we can at
this point First Responders hear an
initial story The Archuleta
that has arrived at the
shop
was she inside let me draw everyone here
to get tissue from from the front door
from the front door
okay
um but she didn't get no blood but I
grabbed the carpet and we kind of like
wrapped her in it okay uh who are you on
the phone with can you show me where you
get her got her from please the road
yeah like where supposed to my dog
okay I'm just trying to figure out where
she was at so I can secure the scene in
that area
it's right there by everything
oh down the road further like just right
there by that red house right there so
you carried her all the way over here
well my friend came knocking on the door
and said something
but as law enforcement begins speaking
with Witnesses a different story comes
to light
[Music]
when he just like went to his backyard
and like we're done messing with his
goats and and we ended up going to
the front and
we ended up going back into his house
and then next thing you know he pulls
out I think it's a revolver the one that
has like a spinning Barrel okay he pulls
out one of them it was a handgun yeah
okay who does
the girl tells law enforcement a group
of friends was inside the home of 14
year old Porfirio Brown when the boy
pulled out a handgun after that he
pointed it at archuleta's face and then
he ends up pointing it at her
and she went
political
give me one second okay
pulled out a 22 22 what kind of revolver
you don't know I don't know you just
know that you just know that it was a
revolver handgun yeah who knows
got you
okay
and he points it at her and she wants to
go like like take it away from her face
right
all of a sudden you just hear a boom I
look and I see your thoughts on the
crowd
Ed
so he shot her in the face with it with
the handgun where where where were you
guys when he shot her with the handgun
um I think uh the kitchen you guys were
inside the house when it happened yeah
the girl describes to officers on
what happened as the gun went off
and he points that at her and so she
like went to go move it
that's when you just hear the loud bang
and a little bit of a light and then she
drops
and next you know she just starts to
bleed okay
multiple Witnesses later tell
investigators it was Brown's idea to
come up with a drive-by shooting
scenario
um at what point did uh
did it somebody start cleaning up blood
oh
um
I
really didn't seem
much but
um
like say something is it okay if I speak
to anything
tell him what he wanted you to help them
do he wanted he has to help him carrier
to the roadside
when I forgot about that but um when
like he was like over there when he said
he was gonna kill himself he kept asking
me or like and like uh
if like to get her to the road
to say like somebody drove by and shot
her I could drive by there was a story
of a vehicle driving by
yeah he he made that story of whenever
he shot her and took her outside when
what did he tell you
about that he tried to make up the story
that the drive-by had been like right
like next to that dumpster in front of
his like on the road because he had a
drive-by happened right there and that
her brother went to his house freaking
out about it and they ended up dragging
her over there but just minutes after
she shot and killed officers on the
scene break the news to archuleta's
Father hi sir I understand sir can you
talk to me for just a couple minutes
um the EMS just pronounced her deceased
oh my God oh God man
what's up
he's gone
I'll have one of my guys meet you I'm
trying to stay out here to block this
off I'm fine I'm fine
four zero four four zero six you have
the father walking in now
uh he's got Carpenter knee pads on a
blue t-shirt and a baseball cap
I'm sorry sir my condolences I've been
thinking I'm honestly I'm gonna do my
damn just to figure out what happened I
I'm sorry I don't know but my son called
me
half of God I know I can't believe
at that point additional officers begin
to secure the area going inside Brown's
home they're met by his father William
Brown you didn't find anybody anywhere
else no I was out there looking for a
casing looking for blood
the only thing I found are like
Footprints and stuff like that and
that yours yeah that's mine
what the I can't find anything
all right I'll go hang out outside and
let you do your thing yeah
the sheets and stuff out that's why we
had the gates closed so we gotta lock up
everything fair enough they don't go
take off on us
all right I know it sucks but just don't
clean that for me I'm having state
police come so we're gonna do the whole
nine yards
just so you know officers then collect
evidence from the
from them
[Applause]
come on
later a first responder can be heard
telling Porfirio not to return in the
home but saying he trusts the boy won't
touch a gun I just can't have you inside
the house with the firearms and stuff
okay
I know you're not gonna do anything but
eventually the boy
says they've written
attorney and
filio sister motto is safe
yeah it's my boy we talked to an
attorney okay
is this a scene where it happened right
it is well she's the body's in the back
there's no scene there's nothing okay I
need you guys to step on out
Brown come on
detectives on the way we need you guys
to step on out now we've tried to
cooperating these guys have already let
people go that we're here so what's the
issue there's an issue because why are
we supposed to sit here live here yeah I
live here this is my home okay are there
any neighbors that we can talk to
where you can hang out no
there's not what's your name bro William
Brown William there's not any neighbors
we can hang out what are we supposed to
do huh
these guys have already let people go
that were involved okay probably because
they already have their contact
information dude we're stepping in and
we have our detectives from state police
coming over and later when asked if
he'll give a statement William Brown
says he wasn't home but gives police the
same story about a drive-by shooting as
far as you would you be uh okay to give
us a statement I wasn't even home okay
so you just got here just now or did you
just get here yeah
I was at work when you get one of my son
called me about it happening did you sub
tell you anything anything like that
he just said that there was a girl that
was shot and he didn't know what to do
you say who shot the girl
you can actually you can't go there did
you say who shot the girl he said a
black SUV eventually though law
enforcement determined a drive-by
shooting didn't happen and that 14 year
old Porfirio was involved where are you
taking him to her unit what unit well
did you bring the unit to the house
for what
that but what he didn't do nothing
he's been a team with us that's it
okay's gonna be in the end of it okay
you guys can't bring him to the house
the unit to the house because it's a
country okay I can't let anyone in there
so that's the other thing how long is
this gonna take as long as it takes
I can't give you an answer because I
know but what are you how long is this
going to take because you know we don't
take anything
I just got to hold on to you okay we
don't have another place to go if you
got better I mean I you appreciate that
as a dead girl on your porch right yeah
I don't have an option either do you
know where to go but I don't have an
option after that Porfirio is taken into
custody of course we do I'm only gonna
ask you two things but before I speak to
you you're the right to move silent
anything you say or do and it will be
used against you report Allah through
the rights and returning if you cannot
afford one one TV provided to you at no
cost you also have the right to have
your parent present during question you
understand your rights okay squad car
audio captures the conversation the boy
has after he's arrested Neil Pace okay
we love you okay
it's okay just keep your mouth quiet we
have a lawyer it's gonna be okay but
you're gonna have to drink something I
can't bro my wrists are all getting cut
into
you have to settle down so you have to
be calm right now okay my wrists are
getting caught into
Barb I know I can't you're arrested I
can't do any about that at first
officials say William Brown did nothing
wrong except get physical with police
stop stop I'm not I'm just trying my
attitude
you have a dead girl
severity of this I do that way I've been
trying to cooperate with the cops hold
on hold on well they're taking him he
said I could walk with you guys they
need to calm down
I wasn't even talking to that and I just
told him to leave so he didn't aggravate
you anymore but you can't keep doing
this because then I'll put you in cuffs
but I don't want to do that you've done
nothing wrong but eventually
Brown is
um about what all took place and as far
as the black SUV it's not that's that's
not in and out okay
does that make sense
if you're saying I don't I can't tell
you because that was that one okay and I
get that but um another thing that you
need to understand is there's a lot of
guns in that house right and none of
them are secured
accessible
[Music]
yes
that makes the case groundbreaking in
New Mexico as William Brown becomes the
first person to be charged under the
so-called Benny's law the bill that was
signed into law back in March allows a
parent to be charged if they didn't
properly store a firearm before their
child uses the weapon to commit a crime
it's named after Benny Hargrove an
Albuquerque middle schooler who was shot
and killed by a fellow student the
gunman allegedly used his father's gun
to shoot the boy during recess
in later interviews Witnesses said Brown
pulled out multiple weapons but didn't
seem angry when he opened fire I
couldn't ago you said you didn't know if
he hid or did something with Duggan yeah
like multiple guns yeah so what do you
mean by multiple guns because even at
first before everything happened he even
pulled out like an AK and oh it seemed
like an AK it looked like it and then
some sort of other gun I know my guns
but it was like about
I would say maybe about this maybe a
little bit bigger it was camouflage and
they were full rounds like the clip was
full but I don't know if there was one
of the channel he ended up putting those
away and then that's when he pulls out
the revolver Porfirio Brown now faces
multiple charges including first degree
murder and tampering with evidence he
was booked into a juvenile detention
center but has since been released to
live with his grandparents his father
William Brown is now charged with
negligent making a firearm accessible to
a minor resulting in death reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie